anything you say and this will be
reflected in your annual review okay
nice that's great wonderful
hi I'm Debbie and I'm Liz and she's my
boss and I'm her boss yeah hi I'm Taylor
and I'm an employee here at BuzzFeed
hi I'm destiny and I'm Taylor's boss and
we're gonna play never have I ever
I'm never have I ever called out sick
when I really just needed a personal day
I'm a workaholic
I don't do that yeah I feel like I
probably should do this more like I come
in probably when I shouldn't agree to
meet you you're so good good sick too
often Taylor's like a really good
employee let me just let's just preface
that he's like he falls all the rules
how to crush on a co-worker man ok ready
3 2 what
oh now you have to say food no I'm
definitely not says right here say oh it
definitely doesn't say that auxin
excellent you're not doing work right 75
percent of my time here I was in a
relationship so oh I don't want to get
too much detail but I've had a crush on
the employee before a co-worker and I
never develop there's anything more than
just that there's just a Connery is that
the coffee machine look at him looking
so good and it toxicated at work oh it
was company sanctioned we have summer
friends where they had drinks sometimes
buta many we have like a lot of work
parties so I've definitely had alcohol
at those okay I was not at those parties
I was definitely intoxicated on a couple
of shoots okay because we're on the
bring me team we do a lot of travel
videos so we highlight a bunch of like
cocktails or fun drinks and you know
sometimes you gotta sip them for the
camera and maybe you didn't get the shot
the first time around so you've got to
take five sips and the next thing you
know your camera's a little slanted um
I've had being intoxicated at work both
on the company and often you were done
for videos okay I've been drunk for fun
before I never have I ever quit a job it
kind of didn't like the people I was
working with I don't know I don't know
what else to say that I just haven't
yeah lucky to work with people I love
yeah people no but I quit a job because
I needed the people wait
hey they're gonna see the video lied on
my resume or in a job interview
I haven't done this I hear people doing
this all the time I would get too scared
same yeah and people like say it like
it's almost like you're supposed to do
it like that that's crazy it's just like
you can't anticipate what follow-up
question is coming nice and like what if
I respond with something that just
sounds really stupid or if you say
you're like speak French and then the
interviewer like speaks French and ask
you a question like what I'm gonna do
I'll sure I do do that
say speak French why do speak French oh
but I mean like I say that I have
languages that aren't like I say that
I'm more fluent than I am I would say
live but like we all kind of like
embellish we all judges you up our
resume like if you are if I worked at a
grocery store and you like bagged
groceries you kind of like provided the
utmost customer service to many types of
people you have to add like flowers yeah
like you did do that yeah but I never
looked wider put like a job I didn't ask
for that's like lying in an interview
here at BuzzFeed I was asked what my
favorite meme was in my job interview I
have one for real so I made one up let
me it is a real mean but never have I
ever been kicked out of a bar I don't
think about it or is this like shame my
friends have and I've had to go with
them but not me personally doesn't count
yeah okay wait would happen I was just
you know not functioning very well I
might have passed out anyone yeah
that'll do it man please just like last
call noise intimacy oh you're so good no
this is like my friends throwing bar
stools get up okay it wasn't me I'm a
very classy lady
some of my friends sometimes forget that
and they get a little wild so I think I
had a friend who got a little too
intoxicated and had like a fight with a
boyfriend or something and they kicked
them out so then we willingly were like
hey sorry like cleaning up what sorry
guys done a deep dive into a colleague's
Instagram two years deep or more it's
like how much I think it's more about
the scrolling like if you have to get
just just I think I would say yeah I
mean I think everyone does this at some
point especially if it's like someone
that you work with her you're gonna be
working with like you want to see what
they are
mm-hmm so you go deep man if they don't
have an Instagram that I'm like can I
trust you did you look at your crushes
Instagram Liz I don't know Matthew I
don't remember that's a yes I'm
FBI I actually did it this morning for
someone here I don't think I if I want
to know something I just get nosy like
so you'll see for some people you really
got to go deep and then like you didn't
have more questions so I'm like oh you
went to this college or oh you played
this sport and I'm like wow middle
school like then I'm just like it's like
when you're reading the diary you're
like I'm just gonna be my page and
you're like OOP that next thing and
you're just like at the end of it kind
of people's diving I don't anymore
never have I ever embarrassed myself at
work I mean we work at BuzzFeed so
pretty much every day it's like me
during this right now it's also
embarrassing you know it's just always
embarrassed I made her get on a table
yesterday and started dancing with me
it's true oh that was fun though it was
fun it was a little embarrassing though
yeah every day like I don't define
impaired I'm clumsy so I fall a lot I
drop stuff a lot I oftentimes will open
my laptop and something's playing a lot
like I'll sing to meeting up my laptop
and like some musics playing and like
everyone's like yeah I just kind of walk
to my desk and work and then leave I'm
in less videos too so I'm not doing as
much like embarrassing stuff like I'm
sorry I also don't get embarrassed that
easy different sounds like no nothing
you just don't care about anything I
threw up at the holiday party last year
but I don't think man Apple no but
that's embarrassing look he was a pretty
knowledgeable I did it very efficiently
and
about their visions do you know you
could throw up officially gone to work
on two hours of sleep definitely done
this I don't really have a story I just
I've done it so we went to galaxy star
wars edge to film a food tour I knew I
needed to get it out like in two days
like that same week and so I stayed up
all night
editing it just to get it out in time
went to bed for two hours or less maybe
then came to work and then kept working
on other things
Wow it really turned them into such a
positive story no I don't think I've
once said I've not to imitate today I
said a few I have sometimes you just
have here we go again making me look
like it sometimes we just have those
nights where you're on a good time with
your friends and the one thing led to
another and it's like morning and then
you're like well I still have to go to
work because I need this money so you
get up you still go and you've only had
two hours asleep like I want to say like
the closest thing I've done this and
maybe like or I don't sleep so we don't
have to get up like I work at me yeah we
don't get better leave well in listen
this is not something that I do often
disclaimer but like for instance one
time we went out like with drinks with
some clients after work and we have like
a 6:00 a.m. call time so I'm like okay I
didn't have any like shocking moments I
would say yeah I feel like I could have
guessed all of these for you yeah yeah
I'm going to get fired up immediately
yeah just kind of blowing employee I
don't think I learned anything new about
her now he's things you know rolling up
at 10:30 you know if I come to work late
he does he knows all the stories this is
good I played this again with you oh hey
I feel like I didn't reveal too much so
I'm like I'm like on edge right now I'm
like woo what else I you want to know
I'll be honored ah it's a good way to
learn about your superiors
[Music]